how's this dude still alive he's not a
neuro dude this is a man by Handsome
Carla I'm Lester here we're on the set
of Avengers I've been lucky enough along
with other guardians of the galaxy to
join up with the Avengers and be here
and get an opportunity to save the world
does it make you an Avenger now as well
I don't know maybe like a third string
of n-draft because one of the founding
members yeah thank you he's huge you
know out of all the people that I've had
the good fortune to work with these two
particular guys and the triumvirate that
we formed together
it's very special friendship and
decade-plus
of time together yeah it's been this
witnessing of like people's lives
growing and changing it's been a really
cool experience working with Lizzy has
been really really awesome and I think
there is something very powerful about
being able to play women who do heroic
things and those women are so awesome so
we've had a really good time
hanging out with everyone on the set is
one of the best parts of this job
actually because it does have this kind
of large extended family feel I had a
bit of a bucket is someone where the
practice I thought he'd be good fun I'm
proven completely wrong in that front he
was odd Lluis and boring and not
particularly funny well at first Blanche
it's hard to know what to make a
Cumberbatch and then the more time I
spent with him on and off set I've just
kind of been fated with this guy I was
thinking you know the journey that
Robert Downey jr. is made he's the
Godfather of all this it's literally
been the adventure of a lifetime
I get a little misty thinking about it
so you know I lucked out
[Music]
you
you